ciao a tutti allora volevo parlarvi
velocemente di una cosa non so se avete
notato come sta cambiando la società
ormai i ragazzi si spinse tono le
sopracciglia tipo moira orfei e le
ragazze invece optano per il look sempre
tipo cigliola frida kahlo e poi la
ragazza adesso sono costrette a provarci
in tutti i modi come delle spudorate coi
ragazzi e tutto al contrario la servono
come se fosse una tartina salmone sul
piatto d'argento alla cena di gran gala
del ballo delle debuttanti e ragazzi
stanno lì un pochino schifati perché
pensano di prendersi l'anisakis ecco
perché mi chiedevo se già le ragazze
sono costrette a coprire il ruolo di
ragazzi e i ragazzi fanno le ragazze
come saremo fra vent'anni lascia sta che
ieri mi sono fatta 1 ma che l'acido si
di quelli storici calcoli offerto 7
cosmopolitan e l'ho fatto ubriacare mi
sono caricato in macchina ho già le
vampe sembrava un trancio gianduia
calabrese
o ti devo lasciare altro frignare due
romanzi o appello che ci sta fa acqua
tutto solo non ha capito qui ci sono gli
amici con me io lo spero perché non
c'era la borsa atene ammazza o uno non
può fare la carità che subito ti senti
non hai capito non ci si prova così con
un ragazzo è già messe sul cazzo evapora
che gli stati hanno visto bene a quale
costellazioni derubati
cacchio amo ma quanto e romantica ti
prego ma che frase ecco le costellazioni
rubato gli occhi ma che sei core a line
ciò però vado paolo fox silos o per
calcolo che poi hanno offerto da bere ed
è stata ad ascoltarmi tutto il tempo
gli ho detto tutto della mia vita l'ho
detto pure che un giorno intero in
politica perché conosco amici di amici
della carraia che che mi batterà per i
diritti dei batteri dell'oceano pacifico
no vabbè che carina va beh vi xi
purtroppo non hai detto che ti era
sembrata un po una camionista quando ti
ha detto che ti va di andare nel cesso a
scopare
ma no ha detto che scherzare da e cioè e
dolcissima in realtà vola fare la fila
con le amiche lo santone e
sensibilissima se non me lo dati giunti
dalla botta in testa ma una tromba da
svenuto uno scherzo e lo faccio 6
rifaccio lo invita a cena
ordino due pizze e poi faccio un pari a
cannes è talmente tanto che si scorda il
suo nokia mappe limitato a casa sua
oddio che apple con dio dio
oddio che faccio oddio non fare cazzate
te lo prego oddio digiuno non so come
vestirmi ma scusa file uomo mettiti con
la maglietta con conosco la view fino
all'ombelico che ti sta benissimo e non
fare cose esagerate che poi pensa che
esiste sotto
e bacci leggero col trucco che poi
sembri una [ __ ] tranquillo cosma è
tutto sotto controllo
ciao che è morto qualcuno qui no ei
piatti oggi meglio così più rustico è
una pizza al taglio si sa forchetta e
coltello magnani mani spagnole mani
sente facciamo che non troviamo ma
niente eh lo so lo stomaco piccolo cioè
a me l'odore già mi riempie è andato in
camera ma guarda carta da parati a fate
no no no io non sono quel che poi i
ragazzi io non
non vado a letto la prima sera lo sai
che io mi ricordi mio padre tramite
questo senso di famiglia capito davvero
mamma magari ci facciamo un altro po più
piano
c'è un minuto che ci stiamo facendo che
vale come un pochino di più ho capito o
no no c'è intendiamo fa sul serio e dopo
dopo tappa spera proventi si ok va bene
perché poi facciamo di mano anche mi
stringente come se fosse un aquilone che
vorrà di fare andare via dall'inter e 6
palle poteva da 1 mostrando il dialetto
ti amo anch'io ti giuro volevo piangere
facevo prima a prendere una cannuccia
del mcdonald's tagliate a metà
mi sembrava per un attimo di vista la
shanghai con moira orfei
by e anche oggi si scopa